the Stillness and non-separation is
already a given it is not something that
must be attained over eons of work it is
already the infinitude it is already it
it is already it so therefore there is
only the character there is only the
body there is only Infinity being the
body the character so be the
gifts of that character you went through
so much
contraction and then
expansion so be the gift be the
gifts as these words flow out the body
these these tight muscles loosen these
nerves loosen because it is
felt that the truth is Flowing the
contractions are loosening the body is
becoming more of an effortless waterfall
of what it is meant to
be